[Applause]
he is the democratic congressman
representing new york's 15th district
who at 25 years old became new york
city's youngest elected official
and the first afro-latino lgbtq member
of congress
please welcome representative richie
torres
hey how are you sir good to see you
great to see you i recognize you
all right well i'm very impressed with
you i must say not just because of your
impressive resume but you do things that
take a lot of guts because politicians
are usually political
like you say your goal is to be the
champion
of the poor politicians never talk about
the poor because they don't vote
it's always about i'm working for the
middle class but you represent a
rather poor district right economically
the poorest congressional district in
america
is that right yeah and they vote they
you you got them out to vote
for you so what do you make of that
where politicians is that just it
because they don't vote in the numbers
that the middle class does
look poor people have no lawyers or
lobbyists no pacs or super pacs
right you know for me it's deeply
personal you know my life has been
a journey from poverty in the bronx to
the house of representatives in
washington d.c and i'm a product
of public investments like public
schools and public housing and public
transit and public hospitals
you know i would not be where i am today
we're not for those public investments
and the opportunity and stability it
gave me in my family
and so the central mission of my life is
to fight for the poorest to fight for
the social safety net
and how's biden doing with that
how's biden doing with that i mean i
know he's passed a lot of things with
child
tax credit does that not deposit money
right in the bank account of everybody
who has kids and makes
i think it's up to 150 000 which seems a
little high
not in new york city a hundred and the
rent is too damn high in new york city i
should be giving money to people with
kids who have 150 grand coming in a year
so it is disproportionately benefiting
those in greatest need so the american
rescue plan
expanded the child tax credit for a year
the president is proposing an expansion
until 2025. i'm advocating for permanent
expansion
because i believe a permanent child tax
credit would be to families with
children what social security has been
to senior citizens
it would be part of the american social
safety net and just like fdr
never put an expiration date on social
security why should we put an expiration
date on a permanent child tax credit
which is essentially social security for
our children
and what about i mean the idea of a
universal basic income
uh andrew yang who's running for mayor
new york he made that a big issue that
was his
signature issue and people talk about it
a lot more i don't think people realize
even richard nixon
was for it way back back when
republicans were sane yeah
and even liberals sometimes that was
pretty little this was pre-march
retailer grains
right because big oh was pre sarah palin
yeah
it was pre a lot yeah it was a good old
days
sanity um but the idea being that
it's actually probably cheaper
and more efficient than the way we do
welfare now it is welfare of course but
instead of slicing and dicing between
different married people and single
people and old people and young people
just one basic income is that where you
are
look i think we are as close as we've
ever been to securing a basic income we
have social security for senior citizens
we have the earned income tax credit for
low-wage workers we have the child tax
credit
for families with children you know the
best way
to end poverty in america to stimulate
the economy is to put money in the
pockets of people in need
because people in districts like mine
are going to spend those dollars locally
which will not only create income for
businesses but for the workers employed
by those businesses
so it's not only good morals it's also
good economics
so uh so as the first um
afro latino right that's those your
words is that the right
saying for latino afro-latinx okay um
intersecting identities i i just know
the words are
i have to pay more jews in congress
because of all my identities so
it's very easy to get the words wrong it
would be less expensive to be a white
male in congress i can assure you
interesting but you could be
insufferably woke
and i think you're just perfectly sane
and a old-school liberal
that's what i and and you know
you like you're
you want police reform as i think
everyone knows there needs to be some
but you're not for defunding the police
which is a lot of your party use at that
trade some of them even talk about
abolishing the police
that's not where you are part of the
reason is i'm a college dropout
and george orwell said there are some
ideas that are so stupid only
intellectuals can believe them yes
and and so i'm an organizer who has my
feet planted in the ground
i represent the people of the south
bronx and the people the south bronx
like most rank-and-file democrats are
practical not ideological
and want us to focus on the bread and
butter issues of health and housing
schools and jobs
and that's where my focus lies and the
police
what people want is transparent and
accountable
and constitutional policing right the
central challenge
affecting american policing is a lack of
accountability right
officers are rarely if ever held
accountable for abusing their power part
of the problem is culture right the blue
wall of silence
but part of the problem is the doctrine
of qualified immunity it's become a
license
for police officers to abuse their power
with impunity which is why i support the
george floyd justice and policing act
which would abolish the doctrine of
qualified immunity
okay and
the other way i think you've been
incredibly gutsy is on
israel yeah and it's interesting we're
talking about the police somehow
the israeli war that we just had got
conflated
on social media among the woke who are
people who actually fell asleep during
history class
[Music]
with with our racial problems here in
america
and i you know i just want to say kids
what's going on in israel has nothing to
do with george floyd
it's not about racism less than i don't
think they would know this
less than half of israelis are white
you know the reason why they're bombing
buildings is not because they're racists
it's because there are rocket launchers
in those buildings
um and i think you're the only democrat
who has been forthrightly
standing with the country that seems to
be more aligned with our liberal values
you know for me the progressive position
is the coexistence of a jewish state and
a palestinian state not the exclusion
existence of one to the exclusion of
other right for me there's a difference
between
there's a difference between promoting
peace and inciting hatred
and most of the words and ideas and
memes that i've seen amplified on
twitter
are aimed at inciting hatred for israel
rather than promoting peace between the
israelis and the palestinians
and my concern is that the hysterical
demonization of israel
has settled off a global wave of
anti-semitic violence and vitriol
and you know hate is never going to
bring us peace it's only going to bring
more violence and that's my basic
concern
[Applause]
right and then you and then to your
point
you know there's a wonderful writer
matty friedman who warns against the
danger of americanizing
the israeli-palestinian conflict you
know we as americans think we're the
center of the universe and we tend to
apply
an american perspective where it doesn't
belong
this is not a black and white conflict
as you said
20 of the israeli population consists of
israeli arabs israeli-palestinians
and a majority of the israeli jewish
population consist of mizrahi jews from
north africa in the middle east
sephardic jews who are spanish jews
right or ethiopian jews
this is not a black and white conflict
this is a brown versus brown conflict
only about 44 of the israelis look like
your dentist
and so i feel like we have to be
we have to be careful not to reduce
everything
to an overarching narrative you know
every country every conflict
has its own history its own
particularity its own complexity
and none of that should be ignored in
favor of an overarching ideology that
purports to explain everything
but but what i
i th what bothered me so much about it
among other things was that it seems
like the progressives or the people who
think they're progressive have
have aligned themselves with a place
gaza i mean the war was between israel
and gaza
that is so against liberal values
i mean gaza is a theocratic state
it's they have no political democracy
they haven't had elections in 2006.
they're never going to give up power
they run it like a mafia
it's a kind of a thugocracy i mean women
are treated worse than in porn
um i i do you want me to make the
progressive case for hamas is that no no
i don't i i i'm not
looking okay no you i think we're on the
same so we are i know this one i'm just
wondering what your thoughts are or why
how progressives i mean they have honor
killings there
i mean how progressives could have
gotten into their head
and this is not just in the recent
history but
in the last 15 20 years we've seen this
with these kind of values that are not
liberal values
look it's it's inexplicable to me israel
is held to a double standard
you know i ask people ask yourself a
simple question if you and your
neighbors
with a target of 4 000 rockets what
would you expect your government to do
would you expect your government to do
nothing now having said that
once hostilities break out it is
critical for a third party like the
united states to immediately intervene
and negotiate a ceasefire and end the
bloodshed because as you said previously
there are no winners in war right
everyone loses amid the wretchedness of
war
but i do feel like israel is held to a
double standard and there is an
undercover
undercurrent of anti-semitism in the
disproportionate scrutiny of israel
well congressman i really appreciate
your guts
and i hope you come back and visit us
soon absolutely as you ascend up the
ladder in politics which i know you will
all right